[Musique]
un premier ministre buvant de champagne
au goulot l'ambiance est plus que
festive pour souffler les bougies du 25e
anniversaire du puy du fou
jean pierre raffarin était arrivé à 17
heures sur place invité par philippe de
villiers s'est tout autant le premier
ministre que le voisin de poitou
charentes qui est venu saluer la
réussite du grand parc
le quatrième en france en nombre
d'entrées avec plus d'un million de
visiteurs l'an dernier
nous mesurons bien la chance qu'a eue le
plus du fou de pouvoir prendre place
dans l'agenda le plus chargé de l'homme
le plus sollicité de la france estivale
je suis un puits folle et de conviction
mais aussi mon cher frère je suis un pur
et d'admiration
cette visite privée mais fastueuse
rendait hommage aussi aux 2500 puis
foley ces bénévoles vendéen de la france
d'en bas qui depuis deux générations
maintenant participent telle aventure
déjà il ya beaucoup plus que les
dommages et je crois que la sarre en
france encore tout seul à requérir
heures le plaisir d'être pilule est tout
simplement j'ai vu le puy du fou se
développer s'agrandir devenir ce qu'il
est c'est à dire maintenant mondialement
connu avec une fréquentation
pratiquement plus forte quotidiennement
que le disent non c'est quand même
appréciable et ça c'est parti de rien
une folie d'une idée de philippe que
tout le monde à se trouver saugrenue en
qu'il personne n'a cru et qui est devenu
aujourd'hui 25 ans après le puy du fou
l'événement avait été longuement
préparée et surveillée par les services
de sécurité depuis le 14 juillet on est
encore plus méfiants mais ce surcroît de
précaution n'a pas gâché la fête
[Musique]